Hey Youtubers it's charlie, this is going to be my flash episode one
video so much stuff happen we we got a lot
of information not everything that we need
to find out who the villains are but I think
we have some clues about zoom in the way there
can be treating the metahuman for seasons
all try to explain earth two as well some
of the new characters and around the reverse
flash ring giveaway starts now Harrison wells
since you his last will and testament you
get all kinds rings wave solicited and are
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video a Mexican at Dublin will be two
rings I'm giving away was a top 10 WTF moments
starting with Barry versus the rogues with
firestorm great dream sequence that we find
out just like your perfect takedown everything
is awesome and then we get back to Star labs
and it's like wait a minute every everyone
so happy and Harrison wells gets out of his
chair he's not that what the hell's going
on let me know the minute you figured out
that this was a dream sequence for me it was
when Harrison wells build-up is like more
clearly this is in a flashback because it's
happening in present-day that he has that
line where he says there's nothing left that
I the teacher looks like you're ready to do
this on your own and then boom it just flashes
into present-day very awesome weight over
the episode very awesome transition to everything
isn't totally crazy and depressing you kind
of see that the Barry has been neglecting
his normal life it is almost their bills piling
up the later we find out that something else
on number nine the last will and testament
of Harrison wells so like it has to be said
here this is the reverse flash Harrison wells
is the original Harrison wells he has that
line reads like I realized they were not enemies
I hope to raise you all those years very very
poignant things I was surprised at how quickly
turned around this is something he would've
recorded before that final fight with Barry
and he seemed pretty evil that final fight
I was kind of expecting him to give Barry
something else but when he said you the thing
that you want most it was his father out of
prison but he does have a really awesome library
says is not gonna make you happy like this
will fix all your problems we confesses to
the murder dad comes out everybody's happy
number eight everybody is getting a bit happier
Barry and Caitlin's reunion this is Ashley
one of the most awkward and I think one of
the most touching wants to do because you
know how much she loved Ronnie and they do
think that he's dead although he's definitely
not dead I know you're all wondering about
firestorm to just explain what happened on
either got sucked in the earth two or he got
sucked into the firestorm matrix is a couple
different ways they could explain Ronnie coming
back to me they'll deftly eventually come
back at a certain point because this Jay Jackson
person is going to go to Levinson tomorrow
I'm not expecting to see Ronnie at least in
present-day anytime soon if we see a middle
be in flashbacks will be like when Caitlin
remembers them I don't think they were going
to meet the new firestorm until episode three
of these is will the slates on all the trailers
have been saying but on a number seven moving
around team flash I risk still working at
the paper is kind of like Barry's voice of
reason she still in the like slaps in the
face doesn't like it of his fog it mostly
comes through when they're fighting on smasher
but she has a couple scenes with them where
Chicanos is the same thing worth like okay
time to move on time to move forward that
was a big theme of the episode moving forward
this is what needs to be done this is why
you need our help get a hold yourself stop
being such a bench the funny thing is is that
this Iris West would come in really handy
during your season three when Felicity was
crying too much and is used but sugar like
slaps around little bit get a hold yourself
of your confused about how Iris is going to
fit in the team flash in season two at least
it seems like this is how it can happen she
was on the given the information that they
needed to figure out what was going on without
him special powers of you look at team arrow
just imagine team flash splitting some of
the things that Felicity does Iris collect
the information and Caitlin Sisco and Martin
Stein process it is also really important
for Barry's emotional journeys with others
like a number different places that they can
fit her in an episodes I won't say anything
about Wally West yet just because we haven't
seen it but this is actually a picture that
the actor tweeted so it looks like he's going
to be a blonde on the series which I think
is pretty interesting on the number six next
stop on team flash six months later Cisco
is now working with Joe's metahuman task force
or at least it looks like he's slowly starting
to put it together I think as we get more
earth two villains will start to coalesce
the boot that he was making for them in this
episode was probably just like the first of
many things that you can be making for them
Cisco will never stop making gadgets is one
the most fun things about his character to
the best ones like the guns and of getting
them in the most trouble I really love the
way that they continue the energy that he
and Joe have together that they did some side
field trips together last season and is, contending
that the season I can remember the funny moment
they had when he went to Barry's old house
last year and that the cougar was there expect
a lot more that level of energy but but now
it seems like there are that much closer to
being super Brose even though technically
Joe would be Cisco's boss on the number five
investigating the murder of one Albert Rothstein
not Albert Rothstein is out of smasher from
the comics is at a couple different aliases
the one that died is the earth one version
are version the one that killed him was the
earth two version that is taking this up episode
to like like next week's episode is called
the flash of two world so that's when the
really going to explain the multi-verse you
probably notice the background of the scene
Jay Garrick snapping pictures of the body
I don't think that he was photographing Barry
so much is he was photographing the body because
he's from earth two so he's investigating
all the earth two villains of the number four
team flash versus Adam smasher most you recognize
and but this is edge from WWE very fun casting
he could come back and you never truly dead
in the DC universe but I'm not expecting to
see him again the season nine the comics he
doesn't need radiation the way he needed in
this episode to use his powers I think they
were just introducing that is a nice twist
and it's also kind of a reference to new Kalon
which was one of his other aliases but on
a number three Caitlin snow and Mercury labs
so even though she is working with team flash
I wonder if she still can continue her relationship
with Mercury labs seems that there's too much
rich untouched territory and in terms of story
that they could use their so they built a
set and Mercury labs I have a feeling that
they'll probably keep it in a provide some
interesting opportunities to surface killer
Frost powers the listener was confirmed as
a metahuman last year we just don't know when
the get to decide to turn her and killer Frost
but if she's performing some biology experiment
that's typically the way the killer Frost
be created in the comics is in biology experiments
gone really really bad with subzero temperatures
so that might end up happening at Mercury
labs speaking of new metahuman's number two
Cisco uses his powers again without really
realizing it I think I think he kind of understood
as it was happening but he decides not to
tell Joe about it I'm 96% sure that I'm not
responsible for all his electrical vices going
off during the fight here's what I think is
going on with Cisco he is largely going to
look like Cisco this season but his power
gives him the ability to see other timeline
so instead of it being like a flashback it's
going to be a flash sideways think think of
this year not so much as in time travel but
is in crossing two other universes that you
multi-verse theory the producers have confirmed
that Gideon is no longer a startle as it doesn't
exist anymore so they're not going to be getting
knowledge about what happens in the future
instead of fighting their future inviting
their past there can be fighting sideways
into another reality so you know the theme
of the episode is moving forward think about
the theme of the season as moving sideways
in a course on my number one WTF moment hello
my name is Jay Garrick so as you can see right
off the bat Jay Garrick Teddy Sears here not
nearly as old as the Jay Garrick that usually
see in the comics use from earth to any has
been the flash for a lot longer than Barry
Allen has two is kinda going to be like a
big brother to Barry like a mentor here's
the twist though so if you member in season
one that's kind of what Harrison wells was
turns out he was the wolf in sheep's clothing
like the wolf in the henhouse the entire season
that is why I don't think the Jay Garrick
is secretly zoom I don't either going that
route again it be the exact same plot line
as last year I have seen some flashpoint Henry
Allen. In that Batman of flashpoint is Thomas
Wayne not Bruce Wayne because Bruce is the
one that died the night that his parents were
supposed to die in the comics like what if
on earth two Barry Allen dies as a child Henry
Allen gets flash powers and the gets driven
mad trying to save his son took turns into
a big bill in that's also kind of a weak theory
to because why would he want to kill his son
from earth to if he were his father and you
are trying to save him let me know who you
think zoom is right now I still think the
best theory is that it's an evil future version
of Wally West it's still someone that is close
to the family and we don't really know what
Wally West relationship is to Joe West but
he still can be part of the flash family or
the other option is that it could be the reverse
flash from the Golden age the Edward Claris
reverse flash in a way where to meet zoom
for the first time in episode two that's called
the flash of two worlds not easy that's the
first time in the comics the Barry Allen met
Jay Garrick so there there's some minor changes
because they met in this episode but we will
be meeting Patty Spivey is another series
regular city and mostly episodes the season
and also just because were seeing earth two
villains the season doesn't mean we won't
also see old villains come back from earth
one like gorilla Grodd will come back there's
no way they would do season of the flash without
gorilla Grodd every mission most of the comic
book Easter eggs but I feel like one of the
best ones is Cisco's comic book reference
here I think I saw the comic book somewhere
my inclination is is that this was just intended
to be used in this episode I'd I don't think
they were to see the flash signal like every
single episode is not to be like a Batman
thing but Cisco totally on point and he actually
didn't get upset when Martin Stein stole the
naming convention that usually goes to him
I think they gave Stein that moment just to
make him feel like part of the team as if
naming a metahuman was part of his initiation
the team flash so for the short term at least
until legends tomorrow starts it seems like
Martin Stein is going to be the new Harrison
wells like the adult advisor in the group
I mean they're all adults but he's like the
real adult if any of you have seen primer
I can't wait for like the flash primer episode
Francisco does work to the science of the
multi-verse and just completely charted out
in excruciating detail you guys adeptly thinking
the same thing there is no way that ever gonna
do that is awesome as it would be maybe DVD
bonus features on all just a great way to
start the season I'm super pumped at you know
the workings of to meet listen to tomorrow
characters as we get into the season is a
whole bunch of stuff though so don't expect
to see everybody right the same time just
to give you guys an idea about Bantle Savage
looks at tomorrow that's episode eight Brigitta
Miguel Savage in episode eight that's a big
flash versus arrow crossover last year they
made the comment that like you could watch
the arrow episode in the flash episode out
of order and it would still kinda makes sense
this year this it is kind like one giant story
stretched out over three different shows so
it's really important that you watch arrow
whenever it airs in and legends at tomorrow
next year when it premieres alleges that tomorrow
is a gonna start airing until like January
maybe even like February next year I that
they'll start in January as reference I am
to be doing Q&A's for this and arrow on Thursday
so just leave all your questions and then
after arrow tomorrow I'll post the Q&A on
Thursday so much awesome stuff coming next
week can't wait to meet Patty Spivey she's
getting awesome character zoom can't wait
to see what his costume ends up looking like
so why is it that you can watch arrow/trailer
videos and you can click here for last night's Gotham episode
thank you so much for
watching everybody high five and I'll see you guys tomorrow!